hey guys my name is J Burleson and I am
the writer director editor responsible
for a little indie movie called the
nobodies which is currently streaming on
the infamous troma entertainment's VOD
platform Troma now and today I'm gonna
be talking to you guys a little bit
about the making of the movie and what
inspired me to make an entire feature
shot primarily on VHS that nobody's is a
project that I started many years ago
actually back in 2011 I came up with the
concept when I was 22 years old and I
had finished one attempt at a feature
right out of high school it took me a
couple of years of false starts to get
it going but I made a little horror
comedy vampire movie and transferred it
to VHS because I really liked the idea
of it being this kind of lost artifact
from you know the heyday of VHS shortly
after feast of the vampires I was
looking through a collection of VHS C
tapes then I had used when I was in high
school shooting little short films and
just home movie stuff and I was really
inspired by the crazy stuff that my
friends and I would do on the weekends
would just grab the camera maybe write
some form of an outline maybe maybe you
could call it a script probably not I'm
a little bit of dialogue but just you
know come up with a concept and grab
your friends and go and do it and just
have a good time and and we did we
always had fun and at 22 having one
attempt at a feature done but feeling
like in the local community here in
Alabama where I'm from if I had a
reputation it was for being a b-movie
maker and I was resentful of that but I
also really enjoyed making that type of
stuff so it was a bit of a conflict but
as I was looking at the VHS C tapes that
I'd used from high school I it became
apparent to me that I wanted to do that
I I was caught up in wanting to be a
filmmaker and needing to cast
professional actors and what's the
latest technology we need to shoot this
on at the time
to pentatonic dvx you know or there's an
HD version now that HVX or whatever it's
called you know whatever the latest
greatest camera is that being is
naturally where I think the majority of
filmmakers independent filmmakers Minds
go in terms of oh can we get this 4k
camera can we get this 6k okay whatever
it is so much goes into trying to get
the money to get the actors that you
need and it's very overwhelming it can
be extremely off-putting and for a lot
of people you have to feel like it's
just never going to happen right so
looking at the VHS C tapes from my
childhood and my teenage years I just
wanted that experience again I wanted to
grab my friends get the camera and go
shoot something so I came up with the
idea for a movie called pumpkin and it
recycled a lot of the characters from my
childhood from my teenage experiments at
making movies and I took those three
main four main crazy characters and I
put them into this movie called pumpkin
and I decided I'm gonna shoot it on VHS
I'm gonna buy a VHS C camera that's
gonna be my big expense to get started
and I'm going to make this movie on VHS
C and it instantly occurred to me that
there needed to be something more to it
because as much as I wanted to just make
another crazy B movie I felt that I
couldn't just do that I'd already done
it once and there needed to be something
more to it and I instantly came up with
the idea for a faux documentary about
the filmmaker responsible for pumpkin
and his girlfriend and it ends in a
tragedy they commit suicide because of
how their outlandish outrageous and
exploitation movie is received in their
small Alabama town I really resonated
with the concept and I thought this is
great you know I can make the crazy
little exploitation movie on VHS I
really want to make but then there's
something else to it that I think
explains how I felt as an artist
than just how depressing it can be
sometimes when you feel like it's never
going to happen and the failures that
you experienced and just what it means
to create something and put it out there
and the fears that we all have as
filmmakers or the majority of us have if
we're being realistic so it really spoke
to me and I I really like the concept
and for years my friends and I we worked
our asses off on it from time to time
and got the movie made so this is a
video about how you can take what you
have around you right now if you don't
have a red scarlet next to you you don't
necessarily need one to go make a movie
you can build a concept around a VHS C
camera that's essentially what I did I
said we're gonna shoot this movie on VHS
C and that alone that decision then
inspired so many other creative
decisions which in a way led to the faux
documentary aspect of it so if you allow
yourself to be inspired by the things
you have around you and take that and
apply it to what you can do right now if
you never get the fifty thousand or five
hundred thousand or five million that
you need to make your your masterpiece
start out somewhere else start out with
five hundred dollars or fifty dollars it
is possible you know if you really want
to do it you can come up with something
that's unique and I think it it lends
itself to a saying which I'm sure it's
independent filmmakers all of us have
heard it so many times in passing it
doesn't matter what you're shooting on
as long as you got a great story a lot
of people would say the story and the
nobodies isn't that great it's crazy
it's all over the place it really asked
a lot of you as as an audience member
but with that little movie starting out
with just over five hundred dollars that
my friend gave me to make this crazy
thing you know we've got distribution
from a company that's been around for
over 40 years a company I grew up
respecting we played at the sidewalk
Film Festival local festival here
I'm Alabama and actually got a special
jury award and we've got coverage from I
just like Dredd central arrow in the
head and uh it's gone beyond what you
would think it could from where it
started
you know making a movie on VHS no one
would encourage you to do that everyone
would say you're out of your mind but
that doesn't mean that you can't get
that movie out there and build yourself
up for the next step that you want to
take as a filmmaker so this video is
really about not shooting your movie on
VHS it's probably not a great idea but
what can you come up with based on the
things around you I took something that
I wanted to see that isn't really out
there and I made a movie out of it and
you can do that too you don't need to be
shooting in 4k or 6k or whatever it is
if you can great if you could afford to
shoot on film great but we can do it
right now with a couple hundred bucks or
probably even less just go to your
grandmother's house and go through her
attic or basement or your parents or
whatever and you know there's gonna be
something in there that can inspire you
to make something right now with your
friends just do something unique because
as soon as you make that one decision so
many different things are going to fall
into place based off that decision
that's common sense right with a film if
you start writing the script and it
calls for a house like this and a
character like this all these other
decisions the rest of the time that
you're making the movie are going to be
based on it needs to make sense for this
house and these characters so if you
decide I'm gonna make my movie based on
in my case a VHS C format so many things
then become dictated by it and it
becomes its own world and you really are
a world builder but if you allow
yourself to step outside the box all
your decisions now are outside the box
and that's where this originality that
we struggle with comes from it
from taking a chance on something that
people probably would tell you not to do
don't limit yourself based on other
people's expectations or your own
expectations of what a movie should be
spend a little bit of money definitely
don't take seven years like I did to
make a VHS movie but go do something
crazy that you can do right now that you
don't have to wait on an actor to sign
on to it or $50,000 to come in or
whatever just go do something right now
because we live in a time and a place
where we can we really can't go and do
it right now
you